hello everybody hope that you're good
new video about Bitcoin day trading we
in a winning strike so let's try to
continue and before I start talking
about the setup of today I think it's
quite important that you know my
perspective for the midterm so you can
see uh what level I'm favoring price to
go to so it wouldn't make any sense that
for example I'm favoring Longs in the
midterm and now I'm taking shorts okay
so I think it's quite important is
basically this uh this projection here
that I'm marking now in well let me Mark
it in Orange cuz I'm not using orange in
the chart this projection is the main
projection that I've been following for
the last uh well this week really and it
was that I explain this yesterday but we
were making lower lows lower highs and
then at this point it was time to make a
change of a structure try to find some
support here fill this week and then we
could see a reversal if we lost this
level and we made a new low then we're
going to go back again towards this
pivot again okay 59,000 but that was a
second scenario and as soon as we saw
look at this 1 2 3 four weeks to the
downside price not progressing any
further it means the market maker is
building his Longs change of a structure
this is a push then get above the 4our
50 ma this is the moment that I entered
and this is the moment that I posted the
Bitcoin 7 the update and I told you I'm
faing Longs now very strongly and price
has just been going up following this
prediction well projection really it's
not prediction it's a projection this
retrace here it came a bit later but you
can see that pretty much followed the
idea and with this retrace what I was
keeping in mind was that we were going
to see a push towards 70k because there
was a lot of liquidations there and I
thought okay we might go there
aggressively hit all those liquidations
and then retrace a little bit it went a
tiny bit higher 1,000 s but then we saw
the retrace and let me remove this back
to the 1 hour time frame let me change
the uh EMA to put into the 4-Hour time
frame there you go so right now we're in
the 1 hour time frame and we have the 4H
hour 50 ma because this was a protion
that I posted yesterday on Twitter well
in yesterday's video I was talking about
two levels I was talking about
7,700 you can see that we actually hit
that level 71,7 69 we saw a big retrace
there and a fast move down usually gets
recover very quickly so that's what I
was looking for this kind of fast
recovery I don't if to call a vshape uh
recovery but just some kind of
aggressive Bounce from some of this
level okay now what it's a bit annoying
is that I didn't jump into this trade
with Bitcoin I did with some altcoins
but in the case of Bitcoin I was waiting
for price to maybe go to the four or 50
and that's when I was hoping for bounds
but it it happened before okay but
that's when you can see the idea big
quick to the upside Wick filler strategy
uh is playing out very well the only way
I'm trading the wi fill strategy really
is to Wi to the upside because we are
right now in an uptrend
possibly at the start of the bull market
so when there is a lot of
momentum and there are imbalances left
to the upside and not only weeks but
also liquidity pools
uh CM gaps open interest gaps then price
is going to tend to recover those
imbalances very quickly okay that's what
I'm playing the weeks to the upside
mainly of the liquid the liquidity pulls
to the upside so that's when you can see
fast move to the downside creat a very
long week Mark the 50% of the week Mark
the 100% of the week and then you're
want to see price sooner than later
going again towards that level so let me
remove that projection cuz it's
completed it's finished what can beit
do next well you guys know what I'm
thinking about the midterm okay I'm
saying that projection maybe it could be
playing out so far it's been playing out
and the last Target that I have is
74,000 now I don't mean that 74,000 is
going to be the top that's not what I'm
trying to say all I'm trying to say is
that the end part of this projection is
74,000 then from there if think is there
projection completed price can continue
going up fine but
74,000 that is the place where um I
think it's a good uh opportunity to to
take profits because that's what I'm
keeping an eye on I think that we are
going to uh sweep the highs and I don't
mean that we're going to sweep these
highs like this and drop I mean that I
think that we're going to hit this level
then I don't know what's going to happen
from this level it depends what the
price action does if we start to see
consolidation above the level it means
that we're going to continue going
higher but if we see a super the highs
and then fall back below the level
tested a resistance consolidate on the
resistance then that means that we could
drop again all right so that that last
part we'll have to see obviously how
price action behaves but I think that we
are very likely to go to 74,000 okay
we're going to go in a minute to the
order book also to have Lo Capital
trying to make some some sense of it now
let me remove all of this and the other
idea that I was having is well in my
opin
and favoring higher prices okay so what
the hell am I doing in the S&P go back
to bitcoin I don't know what I touch I'm
favoring higher prices all right so to
me it doesn't make any sense to short
because if the to me the trend is to the
upside I'm not going to fight against
the trend I'm going to try to use it so
I'm basically looking for levels or
areas where I can open along position
now there are a few things that here
quite interesting first of all is that
if we mark the 50% of the week it's
around the level let's also Mark the
100% of the week there it is why do I
Mark the 50% and 100% of the week well
because these two levels are areas where
price can suffer a rejection from okay
now what I find also interesting here
and is that the guys that have just done
the week three of the course time in the
market you guys have seen this but
basically if you notice we have here
pattern okay Asia pumping
so far London is holding and when Asia
pump you have to be very careful because
it's very likely that New York retrace
is back down okay now if we suffer this
rejection this retrace probably is not
going to go all the way here back to the
as open but it's going to be a partial
retrace and for that you must keep an
eye on this you must keep an eye on the
hang on on this liquidity pool over
here this one there and also the 1 hour
50 May that if you notice is the same
level so to me that's going to be an
area where I'm going to look for Longs
if New York drops to that level all
right um but remember Asia pums London
consolidates London holds and then it's
very possible that New York drops all
right that's what I'm keeping an eye on
now I want you to keep also some
attention on this and is that the longer
that we consolidate around the 50% of
the week week without actually
dropping towards this area the longer we
consolidate around this level the higher
the chances are for us to go to the 100%
of the week so today New York is is
going to have to decide 50 ma in the one
hour time frame and retrace this
liquidity pool or go to the 100% of the
week so that's a
$700 move well yeah around 700 or $1,000
move that we're going to see today the
New York session uh it's very certain
that that's going to happen Okay we're
not going to see New York doing this
that's not going to happen in my opinion
or that's very unlikely we're going to
see
this or
this one of this two but I don't believe
that we're going to consolidate around
this level for much longer because in
this area there is a lot of pressure for
Bitcoin to move all right um anyway
let's see how that plays if you go to
the 50 Ma and this liquidity pool and we
can hold above it perfect I'm going long
and then the if we go again to the 50%
of the week I'm opening any long because
that's going to give me conviction that
if we are revisiting the 50% of the week
once it's been filled it only means that
we are actually going to go to the 100%
of the week because the only Logic for
price to make this move is to continue
retracing this imbalance here that is
left all right so those are going to be
my two positions or in Longs if we see
the price action okay along here and if
we can hold and we go to the 50% of the
week compound here and take profits here
all right I hope that was clear but
that's basically what I'm looking at now
we're going to go into the order book
into high capital and we're going to try
to see if the liquidity is favoring
higher prices
also welcome to the other book guys I
use book map.com
they have also a free tool in their
website so you don't have to pay the
premium if if you don't want the extra I
don't even know the features they have
because I'm using the free version uh
I'm not partnering with them I just tell
you what I use because some of you
sometimes ask where I check their book
but basically for you that don't know
their book is kind of like a book of
orders okay and you can see in this
chart it's like a heat map so the the
more red the bar is it means that there
is more liquidity at that level so it's
it gives just kind of like a quick
glimpse of where the liquidity is okay
well yes move but if you notice the
liquidity is really to the upside you
really don't see any bars to the
downside check out 70,000 69,500 there
is no liquidity there but if you look to
the upside 71,000 Red Bar
71,500 righted Bar and at 72,000 there
was also another bar yes moved the chart
because price has dropped at a bit but
what this chart is telling us is that
the liquidity is really to the upside
now it doesn't mean that this red bars
are sell Walls not at all it means that
there is liquidity there and that can be
in a in form of stop losses take profits
sell limit orders liquidations that also
limit orders so we don't really know by
looking at the order book what type of
orders those are but we know that there
is liquidity at those levels and the way
the price Act moves the way the price
moves in Bitcoin and in any other asset
is based on where the liquidity is it
wants to hit the liquidity right so
follow the liquidity guys war in high
Capital to check where the liquidations
are h capital helps us to see where the
not where the liquidity is but where the
liquidations are liquidations are a big
part of the term of liquidity um the
Delta of the accumulative liquidations
um is pretty much neutral it's not
telling us if there is a position at
risk really cuz it's quite neutral so
we're not going to pay any attention to
this today now if you notice at this at
this levels you can see the spikes at
the right these spikes mean the levels
where there are more liquidations uh or
a cluster of liquidations so right now
you can see that there are qu of
liquidations at
71,7 I guess that's from the 100% of the
week some liquidations are is still
there um that could support the idea of
the week fill strategy to the 100% of
the week and well to the you can see
more levels all the way up to
73.6k okay almost 74,000 now to the
downside there are also some
liquidations here between 68k and 66k
but if you notice the bigger Spike the
longer spike is to the upside so maybe
that plays a bit of advantage to say
that it's more likely that we go to the
liquidations of the upsite first now
liquidation hit map 7 Days time frame we
took that liquidity there at
71,7 then the drop I see some liquidity
at
68k well 68,0
50 um I see qu far at the moment so I'm
not going to pay much attention to it
just yet because for now we still have
some support like the 1 50 Ma and now if
we check the one month time frame we're
going to see that there is a lot of
liquidity to both sides of the chart but
especially because we are so close to it
to the upside
74,700 okay so it's true that there is
also qual of liquidity at 60k but again
we are right now at 71,000 so let me ask
you this question what are we close at
two are we closer to
74,000 that's only 4,000 moves from here
or are we closer to 60k that that's
11,000 move from here of course to the
upside so that's also going to play
advantage and that gives more
probability is to see Bitcoin going to
74,000 first okay so based on the order
book and based on the Liquidations in h
capital it supports idea of favoring
higher prices the liquidity seems to be
to the upside and before I finish the
video I want to say that I've noticed
ethereum uh probably is looking even
better for a long position because if
you check Bitcoin now Bitcoin has
already done part of that pump above the
4 or 50a um it's pretty much back at the
highs okay we're not that far away uh
we're
exactly 5% away from that but if we go
to
ethereum okay if we go to
ethereum we are pretty much at the 4 or
50a and from here to the highs we have a
14% price difference so so if we think
that Bitcoin is going to go up because
there are more reasons for price to
continue going higher
then ethereum is going to follow Bitcoin
and ethereum is further away from its
highest points so you could see that the
retrace have been sharper or that the
recovery has been slower which means
that there is more uh upside
opportunities okay so who knows if
Bitcoin really drops
today to the 1 hour 50
MAA okay so that's around
69.5
69.7 maybe 30
could come again towards this level
here okay hang on towards that level
there and that could
give a long opportunity there all right
so it's it could be a good opportunity
there for etherum for ethereum rather
than for Bitcoin okay so keep also an
eye on on this chart because it also
looks pretty good and that's pretty much
everything that I want to say guys thank
you so much for watching and I'll see
you
[Music]
soon